you've avoided certain movies that were
Blockbusters like what Apollo 13. yeah
why'd you turn that down I don't know I
just didn't really want to go to space
imaginary space or any space yeah I
don't know it was sort of like the um
Bill Paxton role I see and there wasn't
really that much to do
the role that you thought it would be
kind of floating around with Tom Hanks
in a in a space suit sort of just in the
background you turned down platoon that
I did yeah but actually it wasn't more
than that I sort of I went to college
instead I mean as an actor why would you
turn down platoon because you wanted
college or because you thought the movie
was a bomb well it was more like it was
just something that was up in the
discussion and you know I met with him
and then he was talking to other people
it wasn't sort of like I was like yeah
it's yours turn it down I don't really
remember yeah so it wasn't like it was
your film no no no did you last in
college no of course not how long did
you go first of course because you had a
career yeah I was out of my mind no I
mean the idea of going to college seems
good but when you have a career going
you're basically locked in a room all
day with people trying to get a career
yeah right right so I think uh uh but
like my parents always said you know
they want me to go to college where did
you uh where did you get in well I got
it's interesting because I got into NYU
right but I only got in because I was a
famous actor
right are you a terrible student oh yeah
horrible well you seem like a very
bright guy when you write films I mean
you're an intelligent man yeah but I
don't take tests well right I don't like
listen to them very well I think what
happened was I was I had made this movie
with Rob Reiner right
um and he had done spinal tap and then I
made this movie the sure thing the sure
thing 17. so that sort of gave me a
career right great movie yeah thanks and
and um so by the time I applied to
college I had sort of had a kind of hit
movie out right and then I'd done
another movie after that so I sort of
had a little bit of recognition so I
think my grades weren't really that good
but I think
my fame got me in so you you when you I
was like a b b plus C minus student
right and then you had a hard school to
get into yeah I never concentrated in
high school I never went to high school
much so you got into the Tish program of
acting no I got into yeah I got into the
Tisch program of acting then I
transferred out and studied philosophy
law and ethics and how long did this all
last six months
you went from lost six months and out
yeah